>> FEARS VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
RAMPING UP HIS BRUTALITY BECAUSE
CHINA --
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE GETTING LOW ON
EQUIPMENT AND MANPOWER AND MAY
ONLY BE ABLE TO FIGHT FULL
STRENGTH WITH FILMIC FOR TEN TO
14 MORE DAYS.
DESPITE EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES,
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING THERE IS
NO REDLINE.
SPEAK UP WE DON'T LIKE RED LINES
AROUND HERE, SO I'M NOT GOING TO
USE THAT PHRASING.
BUT YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY CORRECT
THAT HE HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT ABOUT THAT HE IS DOES
NOT HAVE THE INTENTION OF
SENDING U.S. TROOPS TO UKRAINE.
THAT HAS NOT CHANGED.
>> AND REPUBLICAN SENATOR TOM:
ON BIDEN TO STAND UP TO HIM.
>> WHICH WE SHOULD
ASK WOODS LETTING HIM SET
THE TERMS OF HOW WE WILL SUPPORT
UKRAINE.
WE SHOULD GET OFF THE BACK FOOT
AND ON THE FRONT FOOT AND MAKE
MATA MAYOR PUTIN WORRY ABOUT
WHAT WILL BE --
>> THEY DON'T LIKE REDLINES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
BASICALLY WE ARE NOT GOING TO
TAKE A STANCE.
OR MAYBE THEY ARE JUST KEEPING
THEIR CARDS CLOSE TO THEIR
CHEST.
>> I THINK TOMORROW WILL BE A
BIG MOMENT.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE HIS STATEMENT
VERY HEARD FOR U.S. MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TOMORROW.
HERE IS WHAT I THINK.
AS FAR AS THE PROGRESSION OF ALL
OF THIS, IF YOU GO BACK TO
AMBASSADOR'S WORDS, THIS IS A
DEFINING MOMENT IN ALL OF US AND
WE HAVE TO SAY WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO RATHER THAN WHAT WE WILL
NOT DO.
I LISTEN TO JEN PSAKI EVERY DAY.
WE HAVE HER BRIEFINGS.
AND THEY ARE VERY QUICK TO SAY
WHAT THEY WILL NOT DO AND NOT
BROADCAST WHAT WE WON'T.
AS FAR AS LINDSEY GRAHAM EARLIER
TODAY SAYING WHY HE BELIEVES
THAT THE U.S. IS NOT GETTING
INVOLVED AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
FOLDING LIKE A CHEAP SUIT OF
THOSE JETS, HE BELIEVES BEFORE
GOD IN HIS EAR AND THREATENED
ESCALATION AND IF YOU DO.
THEREFORE WE ARE LETTING PUTIN
DETERMINE THE NEXT MOVE WITH THE
UNITED STATES IN THIS FIGHT.
AND THAT HAS TO COME TO AN END.
>> JESSE, WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
SENATOR, WHO WAS THE SENATOR?
TOM COTTON.
THANK YOU.
HE SAYS WE SHOULD BE SETTING THE
TERMS.
WHAT WITH THE TERMS V?
>> I REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP JUST
THREATENED TO NUKE EVERYBODY.
I DID LOOK INTO THAT TODAY.
HE THREATENED TO NUKE
NORTH KOREA.
MY BUTTON IS BIGGER THAN YOURS.
AND MY BUTTON WORKS.
HE THREATENED TO NUKE THE
IRANIANS.
HE SAID WE ARE THE CONSEQUENCE
-- THROUGH THROUGHOUT HISTORY
WHO HAVE EVER SAID BEFORE AND
THEN HE TOLD PUTIN THAT IF HE
INVADED UKRAINE ON HIS WATCH HE
WOULD NUKE MOSCOW.
THEN HE SAID ALL OPTIONS ARE ON
THE TABLE AND VENEZUELA GOOD I
LIKE THAT LINE.
ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE.
THEN HE THREATENED MEXICO WAS
GOING TO DESIGNATE THE CARTELS
AS TERROR GROUPS.
THAT MEANS YOU COULD GO DRONE
INSIDE MEXICO PROPER.
IT SEEMED CHAOTIC BUT RELATIVELY
STABLE ON THE WORLD STAGE.
BIDEN'S APPROACH IS SO
CONVENTIONAL IT IS LIKE SHE
IS --
LIKE YOUR TYPICAL WASHINGTON
BUSINESS LUNCH.
YOUR STEAK AND SALAD AND -- THAT
MIGHT NOT WORK THOUGH.
SO WE ARE OUT TO GO ORDER OFF
THE MENU.
MAY BE A NAVAL BLOCKADE.
MAYBE THOSE MISSILE-DEFENSE
SYSTEMS I SUGGESTED.
MAY BE PAID A VISIT TO HIS
GIRLFRIEND IN THIS WITH FOUL
SWISS MOUNTAINS WITH A STRIPPER
GRAPH.
GET INSIDE HIS HEAD.
DO SOMETHING IS NOT EXPECTING
VIDEO OF ABOUT A WEEK AND A
HALF, TWO AND A HALF WEEKS
BEFORE KYIV IS SURROUNDED AND
THEN YOU HAVE NO LEVERAGE AFTER
THAT.
>> GERALDO, WE ARE TALKING IN
THE GREEN ROOM THAT WE KEEP
HEARING COMPETING NARRATIVES.
THE RUSSIAN ON THE RUN ACCORDING
TO SOURCES BUT YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP AND THE MAP DOESN'T LOOK
GOOD.
>> I THINK THIS IS NOT ABOUT
BIDEN.
THIS IS ABOUT PUTIN.
PUTIN HAS UTTER DISREGARD FOR
HUMAN LIFE.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE WILL SEND THOSE TROOPS
CHARGING AND AMERICAN COMMANDER
WILL SEE AN OUTPOST, AN ENEMY
STRONG POINT AND FLANK IT AND DO
ALL THIS, RUSSIAN JUST KEEP
SLAMMING AND SLAMMING.
UNTIL FINALLY THE LAST RUSSIAN
LEFT.
THIS IS AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS
RIGHT NOW.
AND FOR US TO BELIEVE THAT PUTIN
WILL SUBMIT THE MOTHER OF ALL
NEGOTIATIONS BUT GREG KEEPS
PROMOTING I THINK IT IS
EXTREMELY NAIVE, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
>> SO WHAT IS YOUR SOLUTION?
>> MY SOLUTION IS YOU HAVE TO
BEAT HIM.
IF THIS IS A LIMITED WAR NOW, IT
MAKES A SENSE TO ME NOT TO
DELIVER THE MIG-29S.
IF THIS IS A LIMITED WAR, IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO NOT TAKE THOSE
PATRIOTS AND GET THEM INTO
UKRAINE.
GET THEM THERE.
THE ONLY REDLINE RIGHT NOW IS
THE BLOOD OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE FIGHTING THE RUSSIANS.
THEY ARE DEFENDING THE FREE
WORLD.
THAT IS THE FRONT LINES OF
HUMANITY AND CIVILIZATION RIGHT
NOW.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
IT IS ZELENSKY AND THE
UKRAINIANS AND WE HAVE TO GIVE
THEM WHATEVER WE CAN WITHOUT
PUTTING AMERICANS BEHIND THE
BUTTONS OF THE PATRIOT MISSILE
SYSTEMS.
I THINK THAT YOU CAN DO IT, YOU
STOP ADVERTISING EVERYTHING.
FIGHT THEM.
THE THING ABOUT THE RUSSIANS,
VERY QUICKLY, THEY ARE SAYING
NOW THAT IS AS OHMIC EVIDENCE OF
THE RUSSIAN ARMY FALLING APART,
LOOTING, KILLING, AND
TERRORIZING.
THAT'S A WEAPON.
THEY ARE LOOTING.
THEY DON'T HAVE SUPPLIES BUT
THEY WILL LOOT ANYWAY.
THEY WILL TERRORIZE ANYWAY.
AS THE GERMAN WOMEN THE END OF
WORLD WAR II.
>> JUDGE, LAST WORD.
>> I DISAGREE WITH GERALDO.
GERALDO SAID IT IS NOT ABOUT
BIDEN.
IT IS ABOUT PUTIN.
SO THE QUESTION THAT I ASK YOU,
GERALDO, IS WHY DIDN'T PUTIN DO
THIS WHEN TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT?
AND I DON'T BRING UP
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT MUCH.
OKAY?
BUT I TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT HE
DIDN'T DO IT WHEN TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE KNEW THAT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD COME IN IF
YOU TOUCH ONE HAIR ON WINE
INNOCENT CIVILIAN.
HE WOULDN'T CARE NATO OR
NONNATO.
AND DON'T TELL ME THAT PUTIN
ISN'T AFRAID OF SOMEONE.
BIDEN IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE THE
DECLINE OF THE WEST.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
-- I CAN'T SAY THE WORD -- IS A
WUSS WE HAVE A BULLY IN THE
PLAYGROUND GUARD, THE SCHOOLYARD
AND EVERYBODY IS BACK TO THE
FENCE.
WAIT A MINUTE.
LET ME FINISH.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS WE HAVE
ENOUGH WHALE IN CANADA, THE
UNITED STATES, AND MEXICO AND WE
COULD BE OUR OWN SUPERPOWERS.
BUT RIGHT NOW THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOT ONLY
HURTING THE AMERICANS AND ALL
THIS #BlamePutin NONSENSE ALL
HE HAS TO DO AND LET US BE THE
STRENGTH.
HE IS DRAWING THE WEST.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW PUTIN WASN'T
PLAYING TRUMP?
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT TRUMP, THE
FACT THAT TRUMP HAD A NEW BUDDY
AGAINST THE WALL.
[YELLING]
HE WAS A WAS.
AND THAT IS THE END OF IT.
SPEAK OF THEM MIGHT BE MY
FAVORITE CONVERSATION OF THIS
WHOLE YEAR.
WE ARE MONITORING THE LATEST
FR